la page innovation avec maxime le maine
et je saurai déjà d' avance parce que
maxime vous êtes forcément une fois de
plus très bizarre sur ce plateau bonsoir
wilfried bonsoir de quoi les vous nous
parler ce soir maxime et bien d'un robot
pourquoi d'un robot oui pourquoi donc
les robots nous envahissent ils sont
partout et dernièrement ils se sont
installés à la clinique des
franciscaines il s'agit d'un robot qui
opère qui sert à opérer du cancer de la
prostate alors qu'ils fonctionnent mieux
que vous alors il vaut mieux réglée très
bien d'ailleurs pour l'instant pour
l'instant il est toujours contrôlé par
un humain il n'opère pas encore tout
seul mais à tout hasard je continue de
me comporter comme un robot jusqu au
sujet parce que j'ai envoyé partir
envoyer rapidement le sujet
le cancer de la prostate est le deuxième
cancer le plus courant chez les hommes
parmi les traitements la prostatectomie
c'est à dire l'ablation de la prostate
une opération que les chirurgiens de la
clinique des franciscaines à versailles
réalise désormais grâce à ce robot c'est
pas une machine qui opère tout seul
simplement une machine qui nous aident à
optimiser nos maux mouvement pour une
chirurgie plus fine plus précise avec ce
genre de machines ont fait des
mouvements qui sont pas humains donc
même les meilleurs chirurgiens peuvent
pas faire 360 degré de rotation avec
leurs poignets par exemple cette machine
jetables is les mouvements n'importe
quel chirurgien
au bout d'un certain temps on va
commencer éventuellement avoir un peu de
fatigue musculaire les mouvements
peuvent trembler un petit peu
l'opération assisté par l'appareil est
un peu plus long qu'une intervention
classique un inconvénient compensé par
une récupération plus rapide du malade
en effet avec cette pratique pas de
grandes ouvertures à ciel ouvert les
instruments sont glissés à l'intérieur
du patient par une série de petites
incisions conséquences moins de
saignements donc moins de douleur autre
avantage le niveau de précision atteint
par le chirurgien permet de préserver
les nerfs nécessaires à la continence
urinaire et au fonction érectile enfin
n'ayez crainte un assistant veille sur
les pinces dirigé par le chirurgiens
pendant toute la durée de l'opération et
se tient prêt à intervenir en cas de
problèmes mécaniques
pour acquérir cette machine la clinique
des franciscaines à dépenser un million
et demi d'euros pour le moment elle est
le seul établissement hospitalier des
yvelines être équipé de cet appareil à
noter qu'il n'en existe que 2500 dans le
monde
et enfin précisons que la compagnie qui
commercialise ce robot est basée aux
états unis et qu'ils n'ont pas
réellement de deux concurrents dans ce
domaine pour parler de ce robot de cette
machine nous recevons en plateau ce soir
jean-luc orsoni bonsoir vous êtes
médecin choix un urologue et bernard
tarif vous êtes directeur général de la
clinique des franciscaines bonsoir alors
on va rentrer tout de suite dans le vif
du sujet concrètement c'est un vrai plus
ou c'est juste un gadget cette machine
alors c'est pas du tout un gadget
sur ce nid peut en parler c'est avant
tout on a fait cette acquisition pour le
patient pour le patient c'est le premier
la première machine
qui traite le cancer bien sûr de la
prostate et plein d'autres cancers ceux
en gynécologie bientôt dans le digestif
et très prochainement un orl
principalement pour la thyroïde mais je
laisse la parole à monsieur orsoni pour
qu'ils expliquent vraiment le plus pour
les patients justement pour nous pour
nous l'acquisition c'est pour le patient
vous allez nous expliquer justement dans
l'exercice de cette médecine de cette
chirurgie ce que ça vous apporte pour
ses opérations bien le la chirurgie
robot assistée parce que je pense que
c'est comme ça qu'il faut en parler
permet de faire une dissection
extrêmement fine d'abord la vision du
champ opératoire est très largement
magnifier du fait de la présence d'une
caméra en trois dimensions donc c'est un
peu comme si on mettait sa tête à
l'intérieur du ventre du malade donc on
a un relief qui est tout à fait
comparable à celui de l'ue relief quand
on est avant trouvèrent
la précision des gestes est extrême et
le geste apportée par le bras du robot
et plus précis que celui de la main et
donc ça donne donc une très grande
sécurité dans la dissection et on arrive
donc à faire des dissections extrêmement
fines avec des instruments qui ont des
degrés de liberté qui sont au moins
aussi grand que ceux de la main à
l'intérieur de l'abdomen chose qui
n'existe pas en cdi ou chirurgie puisque
dans la coeliochirurgie classique entre
guillemets l'instrument travaille
toujours dans son axe or là on l'a vu
sur le petit film que vous avez présenté
l'instrument de robotique permet de
tourner à gauche à droite d'aller en
haut en bas avec une très grande façon
intuitive et son maniement est très
intuitif c'est à dire que une fois qu'on
a mis ses doigts dans les joystick
puisqu'on va appeler ça des joystick
comme dans un jeu vidéo exactement eh
bien on manipule en fait c'est joystick
un petit peu comme si c'étaient les
anneaux de ciseaux de pince avec on peut
dire la même facilité qu'a ventre ouvert
mais pour autant les passions salée
c'est pas ça leur passe pas - qui est
apparemment les patients sont pas du
tout effrayé par par cette technique je
dirais même qu'ils sont plutôt
demandeurs dans la mesure on leur
explique que le traumatisme est moins
important donc là la récupération plus
rapide l'hospitalisation plus courte et
donc avec une possibilité de
préservation meilleur deux à la fois de
leurs continence et de leurs érections
que le cheveu venu à la clinique pour
tester l'appareil on m'a indiqué que les
pinces et échanger régulièrement ses
robes ou d'un certain nombre
d'opérations pourquoi parce que leur
fiabilité est mise en cause par le
nombre d'interventions donc les ces
instruments sont garantis pour une
dizaine d'interventions et au bout de sa
dizaine d'interventions oui
mais il faut voir habilitait la 10e
qu'elle a promis un seul humain pourtant
parce qu'il faut mieux passé en début de
journée c'est bien sûr mais ça coûte pas
trop cher justement de les changer
régulièrement fait un véritable écoute
mais c'est ça fait partie de la
procédure
robotique il ya des puces de denture
vous ne pouvez pas tricher on pouvait
pas en faire un onzième ni une douzième
c'est à dire que par deux moments où on
les met dans un autoclave machine à
laver pour faire simple
de ce fait à la 10e s'est dit c'est la
dernière
vous devez commander les autres et de
tonnerre vous n'avez pas le choix et
c'est tant mieux c'est en mai pour tout
le monde là on a vu dans le sujet un
jeune médecin quand j'ai interviewé m'a
indiqué que lui il avait déjà été formés
finalement même pendant ses études sur
cette cette machine pour d'autres
générations de médecins ce que c'est pas
dur de s'y mettre fi c'est difficile
mais c'est passionnant il faudrait
maintenant pour la maîtriser en sa
création disons que quand on débute on
débute pas tout seul on débute avec
un expert à côté de soi un petit peu
comme quand on apprend à piloter un
avion
on pilote c'est le haut niveau de
précision je pense que c'est encore plus
précis mais ce qu'il faut pas oublier
c'est que l'intervention sait exactement
comment il va se dérouler donc
finalement c'est pas tellement
l'intervention qui pose problème les
différents temps opératoire c'est la
maîtrise de l'instrument donc pour
maîtriser l'instrument il faut
évidemment opérait mais il faut aussi
faire du trading et donc on s'entraîne
régulièrement hors
intervention sur un patient avec des
petits objets dont on a vu certains
d'ailleurs dans votre film de
présentation où on peut prendre des
petits anneaux les mettre sur déconne on
s'entraîne à coudre on s'entraîne à
disséquer ce et c'est tout à fait
intéressant comme il ya encore des
entraînements ça veut dire que vous ne
l'utilisez pas systématiquement non pour
l'instant c'est à quel rythme le recours
à cette machine fut bien actuellement on
va dire que on intervient entre une à
deux fois par semaine ce qui est déjà
pas mal c'est à dire combien
d'interventions depuis vous l'avez reçu
on on
a fait une douzaine d'interventions et
de cette montée en puissance que ce soit
génération alors généralisée il faut il
faut bien comprendre que le la chirurgie
robot assistée s'adresse pas qu'aux
cancer de la prostate c'est
manifestement
une des interventions les plus adaptées
à l'utilisation de la robotique mais il
y en a beaucoup d'autres
la chirurgie du cancer gynécologique
la chirurgie de la thyroïde
même à la chirurgie digestive dans
certaines indications peuvent faire
appel à la robotique mais on va pas se
servir du robot pour n'importe quelle
intervention ça n'a pas d'intérêt pour
le patient ce qu'il faut toujours voir
c'est que ça représente un intérêt
indéniable pour le patient même si c'est
un instrument fascinant pour le
chirurgien il n'est pas de contenu de
l'investissement parlais tout à l'heure
d'un million et demi ces 5 il n'y a pas
de surcoût pour les patients en tout
l'axé 2 millions d'euros d'accord il n'y
a pas de surcoût pour les patients n'en
est pas là dedans l'hôpital privé de
versailles et reconnu entre autres sur
le site des franciscaines dans son
application en cancérologie on peut pas
être un centre reconnu en cancérologie
et ne pas avoir des outils on va pas
dire moderne juste adapté je vous avais
promis dans les yvelines on est bien
dans les yvelines mais il y en a
d'autres
on a acheté
une machine bon c'est la 36e machine
française mais c'est la treizième
machine en ile de france
il y en a d'autres
mais comme disait monsieur sony c'est
pas tous les patients systématiquement
ne sont pas pris au beau ça dépend de la
problématique et seul le médecin décide
si c'est une intervention robotisés ou
pas est ce que les patients sont prêts
on parlait tout à l'heure de leurs
appréhensions ça nous allait leur poser
la question et vous êtes vous prêt à
vous laisser opérer par un robot vos
réponses
bagis a pas démordu de nouveau les
opérations à l'or bat un robot pas
vraiment non non non non sait jamais ce
que ça peut donner
ça m'intéresserait plus de bien-être
humain plutôt carembault mais faut que
ça évolue dans les esprits je crois pour
l'instant on n'a peu réticent mais je
pense que pourquoi pas les gens quand
même préfère avoir à quelqu'un
avec qu'ils puissent parler tout de
suite je pense ici à voir le choix ainsi
reste que ça si on est quel choix entre
un robot ou mourir sur sur un lit
d'hôpital on va choisir leur bosse à
descendre une chance s'il est téléguidée
par un chirurgien oui pourquoi pas
mais par quelqu'un d'autre qu'un
chirurgien non pas vraiment s'il est
performant mais s'il est piloté par des
humains oui à partir du moment où ça se
fait je fais confiance oui oui ça
m'intéresserait pas du tout me faire
opérer par un robot c'est quelque chose
que je pourrais pas faire
contact humain et on ne sait pas comment
le robot pourrait réagir en cas de
problème en fait je trouve que
maintenant le la robotisation de tout ça
c'est vachement fiable quoi faut vivre
avec son temps toute façon c'est comme
ça
petite précision un peu d'humour vous
l'avez bien compris on a bien demandé
aux gens
s'ils étaient prêts à se faire opérer
par un robot autonome voilà mais la
machine qui est présente à l'hôpital
privé de versailles n'est bien robot
téléguidé et elle est commandée par un
chirurgien
on peut imaginer un jour un robot qui
opère tout seul on se projette un petit
peu comme on l'a fait pour smic ont
retrouvé tout imaginer les technologies
avancent à grands pas mais la médecine
et principalement la chirurgie le jour
où ça sera
dans les établissements privés ou
publics bien sûr ça sera maîtrisée
l'huma c'est d'autres quelque chose et
chaque patient doit avoir la fiabilité
maximum donc on ne prendra aucun risque
je pense qu'en chirurgie viscérale
c'est à dire sur les tissus mous c'est
quelque chose de très aléatoire mais
pourquoi pas l'imaginer il ya 20 ans on
n'aurait pas imaginé pouvoir faire de la
chirurgie robot assistée de cette façon
là on peut quand même citer un exemple
c'est celui d intervention au laser sur
les yeux car une fois clé les
coordonnées je dirais sont déterminés
c'est finalement l'appareil ce qui fait
lui-même les incisions décidé par leur
talent mot et c'est pas l'ophtalmo qui
les fait dont il y aura toujours un
humain pour reprogrammer j'ai une
question vraiment purement pendant
technique je vais vous poser monsieur
orsoni lorsque j'ai testé cette machine
j'avais les mains qui étaient en appui
sur une sur une barre de la mousse c'est
pour éviter la fatigue au niveau des
mains donc c'est les avant-bras peser
les avant bras voilà ce qu'est ce qui
veut dire en fait une opération
classique il des moments où le
chirurgien fatigue c'est pas très
rassurant il s'est pas du tout la même
fatigue quand vous opérer à ciel ouvert
avec vos mains et puis aussi zovo pince
vous n'avez pas du tout la même position
c'est pas du tout la même gestuelle la
gestuelle
de robotique demande une très très
grande concentration et quelque part
vous devez être concentré uniquement sur
vos gestes et pas sur les gestes
parasites donc le fait d'avoir les
avant-bras appuyé sur une barre d'appui
d'avoir le front appuyé également quand
vous avez mis vos yeux dans ce que
j'appellerais le hublot du périscope eh
bien vous ne vous vous pouvez vous
consacrer sans vous contractez
dans deux fosses position vous pouvez
vous consacrer uniquement à votre
gestuelle opératoire merci maxime merci
à vos invités également et donc ses
opérations robot assistée du côté de la
clinique des franciscaines 7 à
versailles merci à tous les deux le mois
de juin se terminer chaque ville
organise des animations montigny le
bretonneux cette année a mis l'accent
sur les arts de la rue est une drôle de
déambulation samedi soir trois mille
personnes y ont participé les images
mais quelle est donc cette bestiole qui
saute au dessus de moi vous le demandez
moi aussi il s'agit d'un des membres de
la compagnie malabar compagnie malabar
qui propose un spectacle spectacle à
quoi rêvent aujourd'hui à montigny le
bretonneux
je vous propose de partir à leur
rencontre ces particuliers
le bestioles un peu en folie les grandes
bestioles qui sera plus rassemblée par
une honteuse et c'est tout ce rêve tout
sous tous ces personnages qui vont
évoluer avec des artifices le bateau
avec des musiciens en direct sur le
charge ce spectacle est ouvert à tous
les gens surtout à ceux qui ne vont
jamais au théâtre de leur vie c'est pour
eux évidemment c'était au départ
quelqu'un qui faisait beaucoup de
peinture qui a créé ce spectacle et donc
certains mots à l'abordage c'est un
étrange équipage qui envahi samedi les
rues de montigny le bretonneux à
l'occasion de la première édition du
festival de rue organisées pour la fête
de la ville pas d'inquiétude rien de
dangereux il s'agit juste d'un spectacle
vivant énergique et captivant c'est
vraiment formidable je pensais pas que
je pourrais faire comme ça votre honneur
les rues avec un tel spectacle trois
jours de football c'est pas mal environ
3000 personnes ont participé à la
trentaine d'animations proposées dans
les parcs de la poudre
vous le faites